welcome to horace hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at why intel's new 8
core cpu is actually really pitiful at
fighting against Rison but before we
delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you got like to stay
updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so as you guys
already know md has brought a lot of
competition to Intel by bringing really
good value to the market with their high
core count but cheap CPUs the recent
2700 X with 8 cores and 16 threads
pretty much made the 8700 cake
completely pointless unless your main
focus was gaming but otherwise the 2700
Rex was a much better value CPU and is
still one of the best CPUs available not
only does the 2700 X offer more cores
and threads in the 8700 K but it also
comes in at a cheaper price at $330 not
to mention that it has a great stop
cooler and you can overclock it even
using lower end motherboards like be 350
and be 450 and you don't have to buy an
x3 70 or x4 70 motherboard like you
would with Intel to help compete against
the CPU it was expected that Intel will
bring out a mainstream 8 core 16 thread
CPU which would not be too much more
expensive than the rising CPU at maybe
450 dollars I know that that is not
cheap by any means but it is at least
comparable however what Intel is
actually doing is they're bringing
another hexa core i7 processor and
they're bringing out an octa-core I
$9.99 100k processor based off that the
i7 will probably come in at its normal
MSRP of $380 the I 9 however will not
just be stamping dollars over 380 at
$450 base that just doesn't make sense
for two extra cores and four extra
threads so as for the I $9.99 hundred K
we are probably looking at five hundred
or even $550
the i7 7820 X actually costs $600 at
MSRP and it is an octa-core processor
from Intel so honestly
could even cost $600 and on top of that
you would have to spend at least a
hundred and fifty dollars to get a good
motherboard and a good stock cooler
would cost you $30 if you want to be
able to actually overclock your new CPU
so in the end the whole
--into octa-core processor package will
cost you at least $700 the AMD octa-core
processor package would cost you only
$450 because the CPU and a good stock
cooler are included with the $330 and a
good beat 350 or B 450 motherboard can
be found for one hundred and twenty
dollars so a solid four hundred and
fifty dollars right there
the I 999 hundred K will most likely
have higher clock speeds than the 2700 X
and it will be able to reach around 4.8
gigahertz based on how Intel processors
have performed in the past but at the
same time the I 999 hundred K package
costs two hundred and fifty dollars over
the Rison package and so it really makes
no sense to spend over $200 just for 500
megahertz so as a result even though the
I $9.99 hundred K may be a great and
really impressive octa-core processor it
is only gonna attract people who are
already considering the i7 9700 K or an
entry-level enthusiast Intel CPU so it
is really not gonna help int o steal
back any market share from AMD Intel
will just end up selling the I 999
hundred K to people who are already
going to buy in tow anyways and that is
why this new octa-core processor is a
pitiful attempt at fighting risin now I
am NOT saying that the I $9.99 hundred K
won't be a great chip by any means I
just feel that the main goal of
releasing such a CPU would be a steal
back market share from AMD by offering
better value and performance in AMD but
I don't think Intel really accomplished
that with the CPU and another huge issue
is that the I $9.99 hundred K is going
to be once again on the 40 nanometer
process if we take a look at the AMD
side of things there arise in third
generation processors are going to be on
the seven and a meter process and they
may even hit five key hurts when
overclocked so as a result the third
Rison CPUs will not once again just be
Intel by price but it will also be more
architectural II advanced and provide
more performance so there really is no
point to buy the I 999 100 K there are
even rumors at the horizon 7 CPUs that
are coming out next year may even have a
12 or even 16 cores so as you guys can
see the I $9.99 hundred K offering is
not just underwhelming but really
overpriced when it comes out the i9 9900
Caidic will most likely be the best
mainstream cpu available but once again
it is really overpriced and way too
expensive and on top of that in just a
couple of months it'll be completely
obliterated by rising 3rd generation
thus the I $9.99 100k from Intel is
really pitiful and it is not going to
help them fight against Rison by any
means and I definitely do not recommend
that you guys buy this deep you because
Rises current offerings and future
offerings are just so much more
compelling not only in price but also
performance but that's just what I think
what do you guys think how much do you
think the I $9.99 hundred K is going to
cost and do you think it's worth it make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to see more
videos just like this one but until next
time bye
you